[Music]
he won the southern state of georgia in
november
narrowly with just 12 000 votes
that's why u.s president-elect joe biden
is back you voted as if your life
depended on it
well guess what now you're going to have
to do it again
come january 5th biden needs his
democratic party
to pick up two georgia senate seats in
next month's runoff election
republicans hold the seats currently but
if democrats win they take control of
the senate
and the u.s congress on health care on
voting rights
on criminal justice racial justice on
climate change
we can get so much done so much that
makes the lives of people of georgia and
the whole country almost so much better
a win in the senate means biden will be
able to push through
policy without resistance from
republican senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell who for the first time
acknowledged biden's win
after the country's electoral college on
monday
certified the vote result the electoral
college
has spoken so today i want to
congratulate president-elect joe biden
but even as members of his own
republican party are now congratulating
biden
on his victory president donald trump
refuses to concede
the white house press secretary insists
the vote result
is still not final the president is
still involved in ongoing litigation
related to the election
polls show dozens of congressional
republicans support trump's
unproven claims of election fraud and
trump's refusal to concede to biden
is worrying some georgia voters it's sad
this is the united states
somebody has to be big enough to say
it's it
it's over i've lost you know but that's
his heart
and unfortunately that's the way we are
in the world today
let's choose hope over fear knowing his
agenda
is on the line biden is promising voters
he'll make history with his
diverse cabinet the latest expected
announcement
former democratic presidential candidate
pete budajes
as biden's transportation secretary
budej will be the first senate confirmed
openly gay cabinet member if his
nomination
succeeds there's no limit to america's
future
but there will be a limit on the number
of people that can attend joe biden's
inauguration
due to covet 19 his campaign is
encouraging people
not to travel to washington but instead
celebrate virtually
from home kimberly helgen al jazeera
atlanta georgia